sometimes watching a movie just won't do
you also want to eat that movie that's
why there's movie recipes today we're
going to show you how to make a Fight
Club omelet that is an omelet that
tastes exactly like the movie Fight Club
first of all do not make this omelet you
worthless piece of crap but if you do
you sure as hell better enough can talk
about it you know what don't even watch
this video there's no recipe here go the
fuck away still there fine
start with eggs but only the most
pretentious eggs you can find like the
IKEA of eggs is what we're going for
once you get your omelette started you
need interior ingredients to fill it
with but like Fight Club this omelette
is random and unpredictable so go to the
supermarket right now go find a guy who
just checked out preferably a single guy
or Bachelor someone with one or two bags
of groceries beat the hell out of him
right there in the exit vestibule
pictures leads somehow it possible
gather a small crowd around you and have
them all take off their shirts and fear
the fight off stealers Grove juice and
return home before you burn your eggs
hopefully you'll have better luck than I
did
I ended up with Doritos a chocolate bar
coffee Mentos and pickles now simply
chop up or otherwise resize the random
ingredients and place them in the omelet
fold it over and finish cooking
garnished with a lid for cracker and run
mmm violent
hey do you see this thing up here you
should click that sony says that
greatness awaits if you do so go ahead
click it you think I'm gonna wait here
all day for you to click this thing fine
I'm clicking it